hello berlin
it's good to see you guys it's good to
be here i'd like to start with a huge
thanks to the conference organizers for
this like beautiful event and really
nice space that i'm speaking in today
um and especially to jan over there who
nudged me to apply to speak at this
because
i probably wouldn't have otherwise and i
also wouldn't be experiencing this
really warm and friendly community that
you all
are it's really lovely um secondly i've
got quite a lot of material to run
through so i don't think we'll have time
for q
a um and even if we did i realized that
i'm one of the last things that's
standing between you
and a cold beer so i'll be standing
right up here at
the stage at 7 pm after the final talk
is done if you want to come up and say
hi
um right so my name is hannah donovan
or at han on the internet that's another
way you can ask me questions
and i'm based in london where everybody
looks like this
obviously um and i'm what i call
a full stack designer so i do everything
from like ux and user research through
to
interactions and interfaces and then
like graphic design
and icons and some css that kind of
thing
and i combine all of these skills
together daily um
to make products and i mainly make
products in the digital music space
so you may know me from some serious
things like last femme
where i helped shaped the product early
on in lead design there or you may know
me from some
not so serious things like drinkify
this was sort of an accidental hack day
success
if you haven't tried it out be careful
it might
kill you with the quantities um
and lastly my current project this is my
jam
where i'm co-founder and design director
so if you don't know about this is my
jam
it's a place to put your favorite song
right now
and it's not just any song it's like the
song that you can't get out of your head
right now the one that you've got on
repeat on your phone
and you only get one you put it on your
profile and you can sort of change up
your profile
customize it to really tell the world
how you feel about this particular piece
of music
and what you get is a playlist of songs
from
your friends and it's sort of like this
ever-changing hand-picked
radio station by people whose music
taste you trust
and it's a slow music service we don't
really encourage you to post that often
which is kind of an unusual thing i
suppose um
we focus on the quality rather than the
quantity of the posting but despite all
that we just recently had 1.3 million
jams posted
which is pretty cool so i'm excited to
share that with you
music and design are my passion and my
life's work
other highly important things that you
might want to know about me i recently
purchased
a reindeer pelt i'm not joking it's the
softest thing that i've ever touched
and i wrote most of this talk sitting on
it i play
orchestra with a real orchestra here we
play music like that
we rehearse in spaces that look like
that and i also play with a comedy
orchestra which plays music like that
and our rehearsal spaces look like this
and my favorite film is monsters inc
i'm about six years old up here so just
keep that in mind
during the course of this presentation
today okay
and my favorite image on the internet
are you guys ready for this
my absolute favorite image makes me
laugh every time is these guys
i'm modeling all my haircuts on them i'm
working on the one on the the top right
right now i think
right okay let's get down to business so
today in case you didn't read the blurb
on the site or whatever i'm mostly going
to be talking about
feels yeah let's just get this out right
away at the beginning of this
presentation so if you want to like run
for the door now
is your chance okay um in 2011
i quit my job at last fm and i was sort
of clinging
to what was left of my ability to make
things which at the time
was not a whole hell of a lot okay and
since then i've been working on this as
a design problem
as makers burnout is something that we
all face
it's not a very nice thing it might be
big it might be small mine was
mine was pretty big yeah and that's the
story that i'm going to tell you about
today so let's get started all right
well back up to 1999 so
i went to design school it's kind of
like art school it was very traditional
graphic design sort of focused thing did
a lot of art classes as well
i fell in love with the web while i was
there you guys can probably guess the
rest of that story
and you know like art school owl says
there was a lot of this
going on there definitely um but there
were also some other things that i
learned that was sort of the beginning
of a lifetime
of learning about the things that i'm
going to address today like the value of
good critique
or um you know creative block or
things like this like what it what's
required to make good work
and i graduated which was cool and i got
my first design job which was great i
think much to my parents
surprised i wasn't doing that um
and i got an even better design job in a
better city so that was cool
and then i got like a super awesome
design job in a really awesome city and
that was great too i felt like i was
sort of
living the dream and then
wait a minute this is not that's not how
it's supposed to go right this is
not the right trajectory for that graph
um
but i was totally totally burnt out
completely broken depressed frustrated
exhausted i couldn't even pick up a
pencil and sketch anything
so like you do i left my job in february
of that year and packed a suitcase and
ran away from it all
right so two months later i'm somewhere
in hong kong
i'm still pretty miserable at this point
i thought i might never be able to
design anything ever again
i thought maybe i'd completely forgotten
how
whatever tap of creativity i used to
just be able to turn on and things would
come out of it
now like wouldn't even drip
and this tap of creativity
is also the only way that i have to make
a living
too right so huge problem there
and then i get this text from my
longtime friend and colleague matthew
ogle and he's sort of like hey
i know you're off the grid and like
running around the world and like where
are you but i'm really desperate for a
designer could you please help me with
something on this project
and i thought about it for a bit and
then i texted him back
yes and it was in that moment
when i did this that i realized
that this is the commitment
to a creative life no matter how
[ __ ] you might be there is only one
way out and that way out
is to keep making
so enough of me why does this matter to
you guys
well first of all it's because of this
how many people here have dealt with
something similar maybe on a less
drastic scale
okay just raise your hand okay so that's
like
almost half of you and you know if it
hasn't happened to you yet
there's a very good chance that it might
so this is a real issue guys we all make
our money this way right
um and you know there's there's ways to
get around this you're probably familiar
with some of these ways there's ways
like this
and this and you know that and i like
those things those things are cool don't
get me wrong but they're not
super effective in the long term and
that's what i want to talk about a bit
more
um and you'd also think that like the
most important thing
is that we all understand and are able
to take care of what keeps us
creative right um but for my
conversations with peers in the tech
community
i'm not totally convinced that that
actually happens
for instance if you did a cs degree you
might not have even had that sort of
like first brush with like the
personal creativity blah that i was
forced to have to deal with in design
school you know early on and um and
that's
that's crazy because it doesn't matter
what you call yourself or what
tools you make things with or how you
make them what matters is that we're all
makers
and that we all need to take care of
this
and because we don't talk about this
problem
it's really self-reinforcing
especially in the step in the startup
community i find that we really
really focus on tools we talk about the
efficiency of things it's all like
lean this and minimum viable blah that
and
we treat ourselves like a tool that can
be optimized for even higher performance
we separate the making from
the maker how's the company doing we ask
each other
well the company will be doing fine if
people are making things and
people will only be making things if
they're in a space where they feel like
they can make good things right
as a quick aside i think it's really
interesting that recently people have
been talking about failure a lot in the
tech community
but i think it's really only the tip of
the iceberg in sort of talking about
people and i hope that as a community we
dig deeper there but
you know it's hard because of this right
so
hopefully we can because we need to
learn from each other
whew all right i think it's like time
for a little owl break that was a lot so
far
um yep this is
do you guys like owls i love owls they
there's so many
you love owls too there's so many
fascinating things about owls like did
you know that they can basically like
hear with their face it's amazing
it's super cool hit me up for more owl
facts afterwards
so that's my hungover owl this is
definitely what i'm gonna look like
tomorrow morning i don't know about you
guys
um okay let's get back to business so
we're in hong kong it's 2011.
you know i feel really shitty how do i
dig myself out of this big hole right
two and a half years later these are
some of the methods that
worked for me um to overcome my maker's
block
and have continued to work for me
actually so
what works for me might not work for you
you know this is not some kind of like
five-step self-help guide oh god um
but an opportunity for you to add
something to your toolkit if you think
it might be useful
right so the first thing here is
learning when to stop
we come from a world of uh things that
don't have
an end instead of like the physical end
to a record when the music stops playing
we have like a pause button on our
phones
and we craft digital things where we can
sort of tweak and update
and revert as often as we would like to
and i think the lesson here is that it's
much easier
to learn where the end of something is
actually if you work with
physical stuff early on in one of my
first painting classes in uni
i remember you know really harshly
learning this horrible lesson about
over painting which is basically when
the painting
was better yesterday night than it is
today
and now you have to throw it out and
start a whole new one and finish it at
exactly the same point before your
critique
tomorrow it's not a good place to be in
in coding this manifests itself
as over optimizing or over architecting
and it's applicable whether you're
working on like a really small
part of a system just one tiny feature
or the big picture right and i had to
learn the hard way
in the big picture category when to stop
working at last fm because i was
still tweaking things that really didn't
need to be tweaked anymore
but the other reason that this is really
important is i think that
you need to finish working on things to
allow other ideas to come in
so my six-year-old brain it's like it's
like a small box
and i can like put one idea in one side
and then it rattles around in there for
a while
but then i have to like push it out the
other side to make space
for more ideas to come in otherwise it
just all gets blocked up
and and there's no more space for new
inputs and we need
new inputs to keep making new things
that's what keeps the cycle
virtuous and keep going
secondly start with something [ __ ]
yup when we feel like we can't make
things
we're on a very steep and slippery slide
to
feeling like everything we make is [ __ ]
i'm sure you've
been there at least once before in your
life and worrying about it being [ __ ] is
even harder at the very beginning of a
project because at the beginning of a
project
we have this extra barrier to overcome
which is like
oh my god i'm staring at a blank canvas
how am i ever going to make something
out of this or staring at a blank
whatever
in fact i hate this feeling so much that
to this day
i do something that i call ruining my
sketchbooks which is like when i get a
brand new sketchbook
i'm just like too afraid to start making
something in there because it's all
pristine and looks so nice and how could
i ever possibly fill it up with great
stuff etc etc
so i take the first page and i always
write book of sketch and like really
sloppy writing and just like doodle
something stupid in there
and then flip the page over and then on
the next page i get down to business and
it's all fine after that but i sort of
ruin it first to like lower
the bar for myself so that i can get it
done
um so don't worry about making something
[ __ ] because the first thing that you
make
you know it probably will be [ __ ] it's
just about getting that thing out faster
making that stupid doodle in like five
seconds
so that you can get on to iterating
something good out of that
and there's so many good examples of
this anne lamott who wrote bird by bird
which is a really great book on
writing she calls upon writers to write
shitty first drafts that's what she
calls it and fred brooks the author of
the mythical man month whom i'm sure you
have heard of
says about first systems plan to throw
one away because
you will anyway um in fact
uh since you know i'm just up here sort
of like exposing all these really
embarrassing things to you i'm going to
show you
the very first version of jam i mean
like this is really
really bad you know this was just sort
of like one of my first sketches of it
but it it
stuck a couple of things together you
know we knew we wanted
the jam itself to be really big which is
something that like at the time no one
on the internet was really doing like a
song was always like a little row or a
little button it wasn't like a big thing
we knew we wanted like some some space
and for
you know some writing about it and today
it looks like this and i look at this
and i still see a lot of imperfections
with it of course but
it's a hell of a lot better than it was
at the beginning it's just about getting
that shitty first thing
done really quickly and getting it over
with
third here taking that small first step
making the [ __ ] prototype
will actually help motivate you do more
and i think there's this big common
miscommon misconception about making
things
that it's like some kind of magical
process where like a lightning bolt
comes down and like hits you and your
head explodes and you've got this
amazing idea all of a sudden
in fact i often experience this when
people ask me
oh how did you and matt come up with the
idea for this is my jam
tell me all about it and i'm like
oh well you know it was like five years
of really hard work
working together very closely you know
working on social music
and the internet and understanding the
whole crazy ecosystem of like writes and
labels and their eyes glaze over right
and they're like wait what it wasn't
just like you woke up one morning and
you had this brilliant idea that's what
they always want me to tell them right
and i'm like
no that's not how it works first you
have to take an action
and then from that you're motivated and
and then something happens you know you
need to let the
sky get dark and stormy and interesting
first before there's a lightning bolt
a related concept to this is one that
julia cameron talks about in her book
the artist's way
which is that we are like you know like
sharks that need to keep swimming
to stay alive we sort of need to keep
making things to stay true to ourselves
to our integrity
and it really doesn't matter i don't
think how small or insignificant that
thing is that you make
as long as you keep making it so when i
felt like i couldn't design anything
what i did is i actually started making
a garden and this is what it looks like
i grew some plants it actually turned
out pretty well and it wasn't bad garden
you know and this felt a little bit
similar to design for me because it was
kind of creative
it's kind of technical you make things
grow right i mean sure it's like a
totally crazy old lady habit you know
it's bonkers but
whatever it was like something that just
helped the
creative shark inside of me you know
feel satisfied and it helped me see the
light
at the end of the tunnel
right this is kind of a big one i want
to talk about habits
for a bit so rightly so
our industry places a lot of importance
on
uh habits for getting things done
processes you know
sort of state-of-the-art stuff a good
example of this is agile right
helps you get things done and then
there's like a second kind of habit
two that's really important twyla tharp
talks about this in her book
the creative habit she's a choreographer
she talks about the importance of
personal habits to keep yourself sort of
sharp and
ready to be able to make things so for
her this is like
getting up super early in the morning
and this ritual of like
hailing a cab in manhattan and going to
the gym where she does this insane
workout routine because that's how she
keeps herself
ready for us it might be something like
you know reading a blog every day that
we or whatever something to keep
our knowledge up to date right but
there's a third
a third and more elusive habit that i
need to tell you guys about
this habit is the one of creating
patterns for
personal serendipity because making
things
requires unusual inputs
we need the unexpected in our life and
that means making space
for the unexpected to happen which is
difficult when we're following routines
and sort of doing things daily
um so an example of this is this year
actually
team jam and a couple of people or a few
people rather from our co-working space
hired this house in spain uh just south
of barcelona it was really cheap because
we got it right before the tourist
season started
nice six bedroom house and we went there
and did a bunch of work
and it was amazing we got so much done
like we had all these
really incredible ideas it was just a
wonderful experience and we're all like
how did this this happen and i really
think it was just down to the fact that
it was an unusual environment there were
different inputs we had to think of
things differently
it really helped us get things done but
it doesn't even need to be that
extravagant in fact it can be really
small
and simple and cheap another example of
this is
i use 750 words every day to journal
and that's a way for me to write down
things unexpectedly tidbits of ideas
whatever it's just like stuff but it's
giving myself the space and time for
that unexpected to happen
um i sometimes think of this
there's this this tom waits interview
that i saw once on video
it's it's really really good and he
talks about like someone asked him like
how do you write songs
and he talks about the songs is like
because you know he's crazy like
butterflies
and he's got a butterfly net and he has
to like catch the songs right
but there's an element of truth to that
which is like without the butterfly net
in the first place
you know you don't even know if you're
going to
you won't even know if you might be able
to catch it and that's what sort of
creating these patterns for personal
serendipity
is all about it's kind of a you know it
feels like a funny thing to do because
you don't know if that serendipity is
going to happen
you don't know if you're going to be
able to catch a butterfly
but without even creating the space to
do that in the first place
you're never going to get one right
another silly thing i do is
another free silly thing i do i can't
believe i'm telling you guys this why
did i why did i write this talk um
is sometimes i walk around the
neighborhood and i look at moss
and i i like textures a lot so i like
touching the moss and occasionally i
steal it and take it home
to my garden yep
um okay we're on the fifth one i don't
know how we're doing on time there's
like there's no timer up here
i hope we're all right okay i'm just
going to keep on going
by far the most important technique is
to do something different this really
helps me get unstuck
so one of my old painting teachers used
to say that
that he would always have two canvases
going at the same time usually one in
oils and one in acrylics and he'd like
paint on one and whenever he got stuck
and it's like ah this isn't working he
just like turned his stool around and
he'd
paint on the other canvas until he
realized oh that's how i need to solve
this one then he'd
flip back around again and work on this
canvas and having something else like
that to help you get unstuck i find
really really cool works really well
it's about taking the skills you have in
one category
and just sort of shifting them a little
bit so try working in a different medium
or
a different paradigm or a different
idiom or language
so even through this entire period while
i was actually
working full time as an interaction
designer
what i decided to do was take on a bunch
of side projects
of print work for friends um this was
something that i hadn't done in like
seven years print work it's like a
completely different sort of technical
skill
but i think it was really this these
side projects that helped me turn my
creative tap back on
these side projects with a deadline
especially are
a really great way to sort of fake it
until you make it
and i'm quite happy to say that i'm not
taking on any more side projects because
i now have so many ideas of my own that
i want to execute i don't have time to
be working on stuff for other people
um i actually haven't shown these to
many people yet so
i thought you know like i'd show them to
you guys like why not
i might as well say this is what i did
so i made these like silly cards for
matthew ogle when he left last fm they
had like drawings of the web team
members on them they were
planning poker cards for scum and i
collaborated with jamie mckelvie on a
backup for an issue of iron man
i did all the infographics this is sort
of like tony stark's
post-human understanding of the world
because he can do that kind of stuff
we also collaborated together on an
album for art brew where jamie did the
illustrations and i did all the design
and the layout
that year also my grandmother turned 80
years old so
my sisters and i decided to make a
cookbook of all of her recipes because
she's an
amazing cook and this included like
photographing everything like making it
photographing everything
making these illustrations and and all
sorts of stuff for that it was a pretty
fun project we made it into like a
hardback
really beautiful object
i did some identity design for a friend
of mine who runs a speakeasy
called the manhattan's project that
orchestra that i was telling you about
that i play with
i redesigned their logo for them this
year because it was their 50th
anniversary
why not and
more recently actually i just finished
working on the
logo for a brand new comic that's coming
out it's going to be out next month
actually
called three which is written by kieran
gillen if you're into that kind of stuff
and it's about sparta
so once you find your methods
that work for you because these are my
methods they might not work for you
it's really important that you codify
them
you need to work them into your life so
this doesn't happen again
and you also need to
talk about them with your colleagues too
this will help each other critique the
methods behind your work not just
the work itself and i think especially
you know if some of your methods are a
little bit quirky like you like to go
pick moss out of people's yards or
whatever um
you know or different to other people in
your workspace like you need 15 minutes
at the beginning of each day to
write your journal or whatever then talk
to your colleagues about them so that
they understand that these quirky habits
are not just like weird and wacky but
it's actually
what makes you a creative person every
single day so that you can come into
work and
do that great work all right
so we're nearly at the end and i still
haven't told you what's up with the
animals
you guys wondering what's up with the
animals yeah you're wondering
so in 2011 i i sketched this little guy
for fun
and i really had a lot of fun doing it
and then later on
owls right i got to hold duster who's
this like
amazing african spotted eagle owl he was
12 years old when i held him so he was
pretty old dude i really hope he's still
alive
and then i got this magic pen
i call it it's a wacom inkling that
records pen strokes
to vector which is pretty neat and i
needed a project to motivate me
to help learn how to learn how to use it
right because kind of different method
of drawing
so when i was applying to speak at
jsconf i knew that i wanted to talk
about maker's block i knew that i wanted
to like tell the story and share it with
the community
but i also knew that i needed to get
energy from
somewhere to do it i needed an action
to get the motivation rolling and i also
needed
some kind of unusual element for
personal serendipity
and i needed to do something different
which is why
sometimes you need to draw animals
thank you very much
you